i've written the same subtraction
problem twice here we see we're
subtracting 172 from
629 and all i did here is i expanded out
the numbers i wrote 629 as 600 plus 20
plus 9 and i rewrote 172 the 1 is 100 so
that's there this is 7 10. it's in the
tens place so it's 70. and then the 2 is
2 1 so it just represents 2. and we'll
see why this is useful in a second
so let's just start subtracting we'll
start with the ones place
so we have nine minus two well that's
clearly just seven and over here we
could also say well nine minus two we
have the subtraction out front that is
going to be seven pretty straightforward
but then something interesting happens
when we get to the tens place we're
gonna try to subtract two minus seven or
we're gonna try to subtract seven from
two and we haven't learned yet how to do
things like negative numbers which we'll
learn in the future so we have a problem
how do you subtract a larger number from
a smaller number
well luckily we have something in our
toolkit called regrouping sometimes
called borrowing and that's why this is
valuable when we're trying to subtract a
7 from a 2 we're really trying to
subtract this 70 from this 20. well we
can't subtract the 70 from the 20 but we
have other value in the number we have
value in the hundreds place so why don't
we take 100 from the 600 so that becomes
500 and give that hundred to the tens
place if we give that hundred to the
tenths place what is a hundred plus
twenty well it's going to be one hundred
and it's going to be 120.
so all i did i didn't change the value
of 629
i took 100 from the hundreds place and i
gave it to the tens place notice 500
plus 120 plus 9 is still 629 we haven't
changed the value so how would we do
that right over here
well if we take 100 from the hundreds
place
this 600 becomes a 5 500 and we give
that hundred to the tens place it's
going to be ten hundreds so this will
now become a twelve this will now become
a twelve but notice this twelve in the
tens place represents ten
so it represents twelve tens or 120.
so this is just another way of
representing what we've done here
there's no magic here this is often
called borrowing where you say hey i
took a 1 from the 6 and i gave it to the
2 but wait why why is this why did this
2 become a 12 why was i able to add 10
well you've added 10 tens or a hundred
you took 100 from here so 600 became 500
and then 20 became 120 but now we're
ready to subtract twelve tens minus
seven tens is
five tens or you could say a hundred
twenty minus seventy is
fifty and then finally you have the
hundreds place five
minus 1 is equal to 4 but that's really
500 minus 100 is equal to 400. 500 minus
100 is equal to 400 and so you get 457
which is the same thing as 400 plus 50
plus 7.